vous avez assumé décidé je le partage de
placer l'écologie au coeur du modèle
économique en faisant le pari de
l'investissement dans les transports les
énergies les technologies de et comme je
dis ça ce n'est pas simplement une
formule ça veut dire qu'ensemble nous
décidons de ne pas faire deux autres
choix est un choix possible qui est de
continuer à dire le coeur de notre
modèle économique c'est de produire sans
se soucier de l'écologie plus exactement
l'écologie c'est ce que les économistes
appellent ray une externalité négative
et on la corrige après ça n'est plus
possible
nous sommes limites de ce système on
doit remettre l'ambition écologique
on doit remettre l'ambition écologique
au coeur du modèle productif c'est à
dire chercher par ces transformations
ses investissements à produire
différemment à l'évaluer à nous mesurer
à transformer leurs capacités c'est le
choix qui est derrière vos propositions
c'est un changement profond de
philosophie mais le deuxième choix
auquel vous tournez le dos aussi c'est
celui qu'on appelle le modèle de la
décroissance
vous ne proposez pas et j'ai entendu
comme vous parfois beaucoup de
caricatures sur vos propositions
vous ne proposez pas de ne plus produire
et je crois comme vous que ce ne serait
pas une réponse au défi qui est le nôtre
vous voulez qu'on produise pour servir
ce modèle un modèle humaniste mais si
nous disions collectivement pour réussir
ce défi écologique il faut moins
travailler moins produire j'aurai une
réponse simple alors à vous apporter je
vous dirai en bonne foi si nous
produisons moins nous travaillons moins
nous ne pourront plus financer le modèle
social qui est le nôtre
la crise sanitaire me la fait vivre et
les débats dans lesquels nous sommes au
sortir de cette crise nous le montre
nous avons besoin là aussi d'investir de
l'argent public dans notre santé nous
pouvons investir parce que nous
produisons un modèle de décroissance
c'est un modèle de décroissance aussi
de notre modèle social et des chiffres
que nous avons vécu dans cette période
certes on perd permis dans les
métropoles d'améliorer la qualité de
l'air et c'est ça qu'il faut réussir à
consolider en changeant les modes de
transport c'est ce que vous proposez
mais une économie quasiment à l'arrêt
n'a réduit que de 8 % les émissions et
donc on voit bien que le chouette
décroissance n'est pas une réponse au
défi climatique non plus n'ont remettre
l'écologie au coeur du modèle productif
faire le pari de l'investissement dans
les transports les énergies les
technologies de demain et pour moi ce
premier pilier qui réconcilie économie
et écologie que vous assumez et
auxquelles je crois
investir transformé innover c'est ce qui
correspond à notre pays à cette
philosophie des lumières qui nous a fait
c'est en étant plus intelligent en
sachant changer les comportements en
investissant sur les domaines les plus
importants pour notre pays et notre
économie que nous saurons relever ces
défis
investir dans les transports propres
rénover nos bâtiments inventé les
industries de demain
investir aussi dans des domaines que
parfois vous n'avez pas traité dans vos
travaux mais qu'il nous faut assumer
comme les énergies décarbonées les
réseaux la préservation des ressources
en eau je pense à ce sujet que nous
avons commencé à embrasser dans le cadre
d'un gros travail des collectivités
locales nous continuons à être un pays
qui gaspille énormément d'eau il faudra
investir là aussi dans nos réseaux de
distribution et ça fait partie de cet
esprit de cette philosophie des mesures
que vous portez